hey guys mkbhd here with a
high-definition video review of the
altec lansing octane 72.1 channel high
performance speaker system so as you can
see it's a 2.1 channel speaker system
which means you're going to have two
satellite speakers which you can see our
identical to the left and to the right
and one in the middle and that's the
subwoofer which is the point one part of
that two point one system now there's a
lot to talk about with this particular
speaker system by itself I suppose the
most appropriate place to start would be
those two identical satellites on the
left and right hand sides on the top
part of the satellite you can see there
are two one inch soft dome drivers the
left one is blank and the right one at
the bottom of those two drivers you'll
see a bunch of controls and those
include at the top your volume control
in the middle your treble and your bass
volume control so you can turn up and
turn down the treble and bass and at the
bottom of your auxiliary in so you can
plug in an mp3 player directly into the
friendly speakers and get sound from
them that way the octane seven speakers
don't actually come with the audio cable
but I happen to have one and I was able
to test audio this way with my droid
with my Zune HD and with the laptop of
course so by now you've probably noticed
the dome shape at the bottom of the
speakers and this is here because
there's actually a mid-sized cone for
all your mids in the bottom part of this
speaker yes they do face downward and
yes it does pump audio directly onto
your desk but I find that it actually
does provide a good substitute for not
having a mid-range speaker so this gives
you a fairly balanced combination of
highs mids and lows with the tweeters in
the top of the the satellites the
mid-range speaker in the bottom part and
subwoofer for the very low lows and yes
the subwoofer is the main selling point
of this speaker system and I wouldn't be
surprised as someone bought this speaker
system just because of the subwoofer and
use their previous satellites in fact
this is a compact six and a half inch
subwoofer that actually shakes the room
with enough bass without eating up a
whole bunch of floor space and getting
the way of your feet if you position it
properly you'll definitely get the best
out of this subwoofer without taking up
as much space as a typical 10 inch
subwoofer that gives the same type of
lows the frequency response is also the
same as a larger subwoofer as it'll go
down to about 15 20 Hertz and it'll go
up to the top of the baseline in your
your deepest songs now in the previous
audio review I didn't actually play any
copyrighted music but I did get a
comment and it's a good suggestion of
just letting the speaker thump at a high
volume and this is the subwoofer for the
six and a half inch and I'll let you
guys know I'm playing the song 5th
dimension by Bo B so you can actually go
ahead and take a listen on your own
speakers the bassline is actually not
here Obul to anyone without a subwoofer
so if you if you can hear this bassline
you know you have a decent system the
back of the subwoofer is also pretty
neat as you'll only have a couple of
connectors one to the right satellite
speaker and one to the left you'll also
have your power on and off switch which
is obviously pretty simple and you'll
have your power cable which is
permanently connected and will connect
to an AC power jack you also above those
two satellite connectors have a jack to
connect it straight to your computer so
you'll connect that by a one cable
through from the subwoofer to the
computer to get all of your audio only
one cable which is pretty nice overall
this has been one of my favorite speaker
systems to enjoy reviewing especially
for listening to music and I have to say
if you're a big music listener and you
like heavy bass you like songs with a
lot of thumb below your feet and you
like to just get the full experience you
can place these satellites as far apart
as you want on your desk and you're
really gonna like this sound so this has
been mkbhd with a review of the altec
lansing octane 7 speaker system user in
an 8 and a half out of 10 in my book and
until next time this has been mkbhd
signing out please